In my last video, I talked about
energy and the importance of energy.
Today, I want to talk about relaxing.
Some people commented that they have
trouble generating enough energy.
They very quickly feel tired.
And so they aren't able to continue
with their language learning.
So I think it's important to
recognize that we are all different.
And I have my experience, I like
learning languages, I've learned a lot
to varying degrees, and I share with
you my experience, but I fully recognize
that other people have, uh, different
makeups and have different interests.
However, I will continue to
share with you my thoughts.
I think it's important that we
vary intensity and relaxation.
We need both.
We very much need intensity.
I have found that if I'm going
at a language, I want to have
a certain amount of intensity.
This will vary.
When I was learning Chinese
back in 1968, that was my job.
As a Canadian diplomat, I
was paid to learn Chinese.
So I went at it full
time, three hours a day.
And I would practice, you know, learning
characters, or I would listen to things
on my big open reel tape recorder, and I
was at it five, six hours a day, intense.
And yet still I would vary my activities
and I would also find time to be with
friends, find time to play tennis.
I was never running out of gas.
I was never burned out from my
efforts at learning Chinese, but I
was going at it quite intensively.
That's the most intensely I
have ever studied a language.
Now I learn languages for fun, so
I might go an hour, an hour or so a
day on my iPad using LingQ, looking
at words or listening to things.
But the important thing is, in my
view, when I find that say I've
been doing something on the iPad
and I feel, you know, I'm tired now.
I've been doing this for half an hour,
for an hour, for an hour and a half.
Stop.
Okay.
And it's perfectly legitimate to stop.
You shouldn't push yourself beyond
the point where you're starting
to feel that it's a chore.
It shouldn't be a chore.
And what makes it not a chore is if
you do activities that you enjoy doing
and that you vary these activities.
So right now in Arabic.
I'm listening to, uh, interviews
in Arabic in particular.
I'm going through an interview with Carlos
Rosen, who is the Lebanese, Brazilian,
French president of Nissan in Japan,
amongst other things in his career.
And it's a very interesting story.
And he's a fascinating person
to listen to in four languages.
And of course, on YouTube, I can find
his interviews in different languages
and the Arabic ones, I bring them in and
I study them on LingQ, but I do them.
I enjoy them.
And to me, the important
thing is that I am active.
Another aspect of relaxation,
and I liken sort of language
learning to long distance running.
If I'm going to go for a jog for
half an hour Uh, through the forest,
uh, I'm not going to sprint because
I've got to make it all the way back.
And I intend to enjoy the
run through the forest.
That's not to say that it
may not be a good thing at
times to sprint a little bit.
You know, you have this fart leg
run, uh, little bit of aerobic
and then anaerobic activity, but
basically I have to pace myself.
Another thing about pacing
yourself is that you have to have.
Good sleeping habits.
Again, easily said, there are some
people who have trouble sleeping.
I don't know.
I certainly never sleep through
the night, but, uh, sleep is
where we kind of consolidate the
things that we've been learning.
So I sometimes hear people say,
well, you know, I'm going to
put my Spanish or Chinese on
and fall asleep listening to it.
And that way I'll learn it while sleeping.
All you do is ruin your sleep.
I will leave a link to an article
from a website called News in Health.
And it explains just how important sleep
is to consolidate what you have learned,
to consolidate the memories, how the
brain continues to hang on to the things
that you have learned during the day.
So, sleep is important.
Another thing that I think is relevant to
this discussion of, you know, intensity
and then relaxation, is that I have
always found that if I leave a language.
For a while, and particularly if I
study another language, then when
I come back to the first language,
I'm often better than I was.
I've called this sort of benign neglect,
and I'm not sure whether the language
continues to gestate in your brain.
Or whether it's because you
tried this other language and
struggled with that for a while.
Then you come back to the first
one and the first one seems easier.
But I have always found that,
that there is no loss in
leaving a language for a while.
Other than the fact that you're not
spending that time with the language.
So you will So maybe you should, you
know, perhaps progress more slowly by not
having spent the time with the language.
However, you won't slip very much.
And so I often hear people say that
they're afraid to stop working on
this language because they're actually
interested in this other language and
then they'll lose the first language.
I've never found that to be the case.
I think we can vary intensity with periods
of benign neglect where we don't do
anything and we don't suffer that much.
And if we come back refreshed,
then so much the better.
And now it's important to remember.
That when we're studying, we shouldn't be
too fussed, and I mentioned this in the
last video about energy, we shouldn't be
too fussed about how much we're learning.
Like, I've gotta learn this, and I have
to go through all these flashcards,
and I have to do this and that.
All of that pressure is
sort of counterproductive.
You have to have the confidence and
the trust that your brain is learning.
That as long as you are
active, That you will learn.
People sometimes ask me, Oh, Steve,
you have this number, so many
known words, 20, 000 known words.
Do you really know those words?
Can you produce those words?
And I say, well, probably not.
However, it reflects the fact that
when I see that word on a text
in LingQ, I don't save it because
I understand it in that context.
Eventually, I will be able
to use it, but no guarantees.
However, those statistics, known words,
number of LingQs created on LingQ,
hours of listening even, All of those
are measures of your activity because
the most important thing is that you
stay with the task and remain active.
Don't put pressure on yourself.
Don't force yourself to do
activities that you don't like to do.
Don't do things that are likely
to make you run out of energy.
Vary the activities.
Very studying hard with relaxation
by all means, find someone, if you
can find someone to talk to in the
language and that if it's a low
stress environment, that's all good.
So I think we don't all have
the same level of energy.
We should all be mixing
in periods of relaxation.
We shouldn't be afraid either to
relax or to study another language.
We should apply the level of
energy that we have and do things
that either require less energy.
Or, give us a sense of energy.
And part of that is to give yourself
credit for what you're doing.
And mainly that means give yourself
credit for being active, remaining
active in learning the language.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.